what is going on everybody and welcome
to part two of our playing with robotic
arm series where we're going to at least
be starting with attempting to play air
hockey so there's a few questions that
come into play right out of the gate
which is but you know how are we gonna
pass data basically to the arm in order
to actually understand like what's going
on
so there is an on-board camera that you
could have on the arm itself and then
there's also like having an overhead
camera now from a lot of thought and
contemplation I like the idea of an
on-board camera but I think at least you
know so sometimes you want to make
things as simple as possible and I think
that an overhead camera is likely the
simplest thing to at least start with
and then maybe later we could try to use
an overhead camera onboard camera rather
so going with the overhead camera idea
the the thought that I had was to
basically let me pull up here so you can
actually see it in the background of the
video but basically I've got the air
hockey table on the floor and then I've
got a camera pointed down on a piece of
wood basically and that's that's how
I've got it pointed at the table but let
me pull up an image so basically this is
what the the camera sees so obviously
we've got some stuff around the edges
but this is the playing space so this is
our robot arm and then this is the puck
and I think basically what we want to do
is stop saying basically every five
seconds but we would like to also we
want to know where the edges of the the
playing board are possibly if there is
another player you'd want to be able to
identify where is their striker
otherwise you really just want to know
where the puck is in relation to
yourself and that's about it so that's
the the first task is really just an
image analysis type of task and that is
find the puck now there's lots of ways
that we could find the puck you could go
now
the object detection route you could go
down and there's a bunch of different
you could use the tensorflow object
detection api or you could use more
crude forms of object detection the
other option you have is like circle
detection you can do that with an open
CV the other one we have is is we could
go based on color so this is a nice deep
red nothing else really matches this red
except for the red over here so we could
filter out and find the puck based on
color and that's the method I'm gonna go
with right now but if someone else has
an idea for a method that might be
quicker as far as processing is
concerned so everything is about how
quickly can we actually process this
because this would be a live game and
the quicker that we can process the real
camera data the better we're going to be
actually playing the game so anyways I'm
just gonna show the first path I've
taken to go through this the task of
identifying the puck
I'm confident there's better ways and
I'm confident someone watching can come
up with something better than I've done
so feel free to submit your ideas if
you'd like so this is the example I'm
gonna host this image and then maybe
later I'll even host like a video
because the other thing that matters is
when you do filter by color just the
changing daylight is enough to or just
changing ambient light is enough to
cause trouble so probably what I'll do
is at least for now we're just gonna try
to find the puck on a still frame then
I'll post a video and then maybe I'll
post a video with various lighting
backgrounds and see if anybody can come
up with a really good way to detect the
puck also since I did this I actually
taped you can't really see it right now
but the little striker
I used painter like blue painters tape
so the striker is no longer red so that
kind of helps a little bit anyway let's
go ahead and get into it so I'm just
gonna I think oh we might want this
again so I'm just gonna move it aside
and the way that I'm gonna do is use
color filtering and we've already done
this before so I'm not going to waste
anybody's time but if you get a Python
program
go to data analysis and image and video
analysis we can come down here and
trying to see the color filtering and
Thresh holding will be useful but
actually if you just look at this
picture this is an important picture to
think about I'm not sure if I include it
in the tutorial but it's super useful
right here so what we're going to do is
we're gonna kind of just take the code
that I used here and then also the
blurring and smoothing I believe I'm
going to steal from yeah so there's just
a bunch of different ways that we can
apply blurs and stuff like that and
smoothing operations to to better get
the object that we're attempting to
filter for so you can see these are just
different examples so so what I'm gonna
do is I think first I'm just gonna copy
and paste over the code that I've got
that will at least get us there and I'll
just explain it and again this is all
code that there's tutorials on already
so I don't really want to spend any time
talking about it or at least writing it
out anyways I'll tell you what's going
on though so first we're gonna convert
to this HSV so just looking at this
picture here from the previous tutorial
it actually is a pretty useful so you've
got the hue the saturation value and I
wish that play button was in the way I
swear I had this picture somewhere
anyway let's see if I can find like a
picture of hue saturation use a shirt
value see if I could do like meaning or
something that would probably come up
with a good one yeah here we go
so here you can see hue is more like
your color choice the value is basically
how bright is that color and the
saturation is basically how much of that
color do we have how full is that color
so I'm sure someone's gonna have a gripe
with the way I've described that but you
can look at the picture and get an idea
for what I mean there and so this
actually makes for a pretty good way to
filter by color rather than using RGB or
BGR or whatever so anyways I'm gonna get
out of here and keep what I did so I
went ahead and this is probably the most
tedious part of the operation is just
trying to find which values you
to go with I just found that these were
some good values in general basically if
you want to go through this you can just
start setting things like all at zero so
basically the lower is all zeros the
upper is all 255 max out and then you
just start trimming away the bottom and
go back a little bit once you've got
lost what you were hoping for turn away
the top and then go back once you've
lost what you were hoping to find and
boom you've got it so so let me go ahead
and run that show you what we're kind of
hoping for us so this was just like the
original image coming in and then this
is just with some averaging blurring
this is the Gaussian blur
this is median blur and I don't even see
the object anymore and then we've got a
bilateral blur so the bilateral blur
right now looks does look the best but
you're gonna threshold anyways most
likely and it's just really not gonna
matter so any of these like like this
one looks like it actually picks up some
stuff down here whereas these ones don't
as much so it might be better to just go
with the averaging one or whatever but
yeah all these are doing is just
applying these various blurs meshing
them together and then only showing what
meets a certain a certain threshold
basically that is the lower red and the
upper red as far as filtering by color
is concerned so that's how we're gonna
go about at least filtering but then the
next thing is basically how do we how do
we go about really truly finding the the
puck itself and so the way that I went
ahead and did that is I stuck with the
Gaussian blur but I actually think
averaging with smooth is actually
probably better I might even just take
that
so rather than any of the blurs let's
see I'm going to take where's averaged
our averaging is just smooth with the
kernel there so then we'll just do this
I think that's all we need to do let me
rerun that real quick yeah okay so I
think this one actually looks the best
right now so I'm gonna go with that one
and then if we wanted to
we could apply a threshold and so I'm
gonna just copy this copy and then I'm
just gonna paste this down here so then
what we can do is we can apply the
threshold say what our limits are and
we're gonna do the threshold rather than
onblur I'm actually gonna do it on
smooth I like that one better let me run
that again and so let's see
oh we're not sure we are showing puck
where did puck go why do I not see puck
oh it's up here okay so puck
unfortunately so I had initially done
this with a different blur so we
probably need to come up with a
different range here I'm guessing we
need to accept a darker range so let me
go with like a thirty and see how that
one goes yeah that looks really good so
as you can see here this was the
original image this is after averaging
and then this is once we threshold for
you know really finding just the puck
and so clearly I think everyone would
agree that looks really good now the
next thing is you know how okay once we
find the puck all we've done is filter
for the puck how do we get the value for
the puck because at the end of the day
we have to translate this data to the
robotic arm so the way that we can go
about doing that is because we've done a
threshold like if we were to actually
just print print owl puck you can see
most of the values are actually going to
be zero so instead what we're gonna be
looking for is basically you would want
to look for let's see if we do have none
pi so you'd want to look through the
puck which is just an array it's an
umpire array of X's and Y's we won't we
will want to look through that and find
any instance and it's also been Thresh
held so we want to find any instance
where it's basically not zero and we
want to know where are those instances
where it's not zero so for example what
we could say is print and P dot where
and then the where clause is basically
where puck doesn't equal zero and then
so we could just print that and then we
get kind of this but then what we could
say or could query is
rather than MP where puck does not equal
zero we could say well this is zero and
then we can do the exact same thing for
the first if boom and then we can see so
for the zero with I actually I will
recall right it's nine in OpenCV it's
actually you're not getting coordinates
in like X Y you're actually getting them
in a Y X we can confirm that in a little
bit
but this is basically so like if you
wanted to figure out like if we look at
this we can clearly see ok 61 62 63 so
so you can be relatively confident this
is all these are all the puck right
because they're very close to each other
and then coming down here again these
are all very very close to each other so
one option we have is we could actually
probably just take this calculate the
average and boom you've got the average
Y and then come down here calculate the
average and boom we've got the average X
now the last thing I want to do is
convert rather than doing this on a
table I'm actually kind of curious about
if this is actually a superior option
than what I was doing before because
that actually looks really good right
now now the lighting is pretty dim it's
actually kind of stormy today outside so
I'm actually I'm kind of curious this
one might be superior I had like I said
I've been using the the Gaussian blur so
instead what I'm gonna do is let's see
how easily I can just modify this so
rather than here I think all we need to
do let me just copy and paste some stuff
real quick and I'll explain what I'm
doing here so this is just a rescale
factor and basically what I'm trying to
do is the camera is actually at 1280 by
720 but I don't want to display it that
big on my screen there in there there's
also no reason to have that much
resolution so I'm just gonna do it half
of that basically I'm also capturing the
first camera not the zeroeth because I'm
recording on my 0 with camera the
secondary camera is over there so that's
why I'm changing that to 1 but if you
were to follow along and you had your
own a little table or whatever you were
probably gonna use 0 is my guess so now
what we would want to do is Wow
1
and then let's go ahead and tap all this
over the frame itself would actually be
capture read so let's just a underscore
frame fame frame equals cap dots read we
don't need this anymore
and let's see frame will convert the
frame immediately there so now the only
thing we need is we can't really get
away with this wait key anymore and in
fact I don't think we can just say cb2
let's just do this this one always works
for me there's an easier way I'm pretty
sure but let's just do this copy-paste
cool okay let me try and run that real
quick let's see we run into so far that
looks okay but we don't have anything
for the puck which is awkward what a
bummer I think it's because of the
lighting situation though anything so
the other one was a little brighter so I
mean we could try to lower a couple
things I don't want to spend too long
trying to do this but anyway that that
seems to have helped some puck does look
really good
we do have some edge data here that we
probably don't actually want let me just
see I'm hoping I can get rid of wow we
got rid of the top that's a weird I
forget we even started with to be honest
50 over there getting closer getting
closer
darn mm-hmm let's go to 160 then okay
that's pretty good now I'm gonna go bump
the puck real quick mmm that doesn't
appear to I want to actually track that
puck let me go back down to maybe a 150
there let's see if the puck comes back
up it does let me plug in the table too
now that still doesn't want to track it
it like disappears over some spots which
is just kind of weird not sure why that
would be happening I might go back to my
original original value why would it I
wonder why it would not be noticed good
so I mean I guess maybe it's slightly
more dim there but there's no shadow
that I can see over there that's really
crazy
let's do eventually it's gonna get like
super excited now we can get rid of the
are the edges yeah that one appears to
be visible in most locations
goes away still in that shadow which is
really weird
anyway I'll tweak more of that later but
then the next things that we have to
deal with are basically you know getting
around the edges here kind of cleaning
this up a little bit and then I'll kind
of poke around with these other values
but yeah now that we have the puck and
we can kind of we'll do a couple things
one is hopefully we'll kind of clean
this up a little bit we'll remove these
edges here and then the other thing that
we're going to try to do is actually get
the center of the puck and that's the
final bit of data that we really need to
be able to pass to our arms so that's
what we're going to be doing in the next
tutorial if you've got questions
comments concerns a better way to detect
the puck whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise I'll see you
another video